>> Bret: LET'S GET SOME
PERSPECTIVE NOW AND INSIDE ARE
THE STORIES THAT WE BROUGHT YOU
BEFORE THE BREAK.
IF THE NORTH KOREA HOSTAGE
SETTLEMENTS AND WHAT GAMES COMES
NEXT, THE IRAN DEAL AND OTHER
STORIES.
BRIT HUME JOINS US.
YOUR THOUGHTS ON, THIS IS A BIG
DEVELOPMENT WITH THESE THREE
AMERICANS LANDING TONIGHT OR
EARLY THIS MORNING, BUT IT IS
SETTING THE TABLE FOR WHAT THE
PRESIDENT HOPES WILL BE
SOMETHING BIGGER.
>> INDEED, AND YOU HAVE THE
PRESIDENT NOW BEING CONFRONTED
WITH QUESTIONS ABOUT WHETHER HE
IS A LIKELY CANDIDATE FOR THE
NOBEL PRIZE.
TO SOME EXTENT, AT LEAST HE HAS
PUSHED BACK AGAINST THAT IDEA
BUT I THINK HE REALLY DOES
OBVIOUSLY HOPE THAT THIS WAS
GOING TO TURN INTO AN AGREEMENT,
INCREDIBLE ENFORCEABLE AND
VERIFIABLE AGREEMENT ON THE DUDE
DENUCLEARIZATION OF THE KOREAN
PENINSULA WHICH WOULD BE A HUGE
ACHIEVEMENT.
NOW THIS THING THAT HAPPENED
TODAY, THE RETURN OF THESE
HOSTAGES, IT IS IMPORTANT IN THE
SENSE THAT IT WASN'T VERY MANY
MONTHS AGO, BRET, THAT PEOPLE
WERE SAYING THAT WITH HIS SABER
RATTLING AND BELLICOSE ATTITUDE,
HE WAS BRINGING US TO THE BRINK
OF WAR.
WE HEARD THAT A LOT, AND LOOK
WHERE WE ARE NOW.
IT DOESN'T MEAN WE ARE HEADED TO
THE LAND OF HOPE AND GLORY OVER
THERE BUT IT IS A SIGNIFICANT
ACHIEVEMENT TO GET THIS FAR.
OBVIOUSLY, LOTS OF REMAINS TO BE
SEEN.
>> Bret: THE OTHER BIG NUCLEAR
ISSUE ON IRONIC, IT SEEMS THAT
EUROPEANS ARE TRYING TO TALK TO
IRAN SEPARATE FROM THE U.S.
PULLING OUT OF THIS DEAL BUT IT
DOESN'T SEEM LIKE A REALISTIC
PLOT PROSPECT.
>> THE KEY QUESTION HERE IS, HOW
MUCH DIFFERENCE TO IRAN WILL THE
RE-IMPOSITION OF AMERICAN
SANCTIONS MAKE.
THE AMERICAN BANKING SYSTEM IS
CENTRAL TO THE WHOLE ECONOMY.
OUR ALLIES DON'T WANT TO RUN
AFOUL OF THAT EITHER, AND THAT
MAY MAKE A DIFFERENCE TO IRAN
AND TO OUR ALLIES.
AND WE CAN'T TELL THEM NOW.
A LOT OF PEOPLE, YOU HEAR PEOPLE
FROM THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION
SAYING, THIS IS A DISASTER.
ALL THE CYCLES ARE OFF, AND I'M